all right we're going to begin this hour
with a story about Second Chances and
finding a new purpose in life Nancy Chen
visited a radio station that's become
the first of its kind in the country and
she got to know a little bit more about
the powerful stories of the people
behind the microphone
it is 42 past the hour spinning this
music for you man
90 miles east of Denver this Colorado
radio station runs like any other I'm
your host Benny Hill and I've got a good
show in store for you today but the
audio hosts are inmates here in Lyman
Correctional Facility testing Mike one
testing Mike two Jody Aguirre has been
in prison for three decades where he
goes and when are strictly limited but
his voice is one of a handful so imagine
the scenery as you listen to the words
of this song now traveling far beyond
the bark wire fences broadcast to all of
Colorado's correctional facilities and
streamed online to the public this is
inside wire the nation's first and only
Statewide prison radio system coming up
right now we're going to go into a nice
soft song what do you like most about
being on a radio station we are being
something better than we've been told
we've been all of our Lives it's
appreciate that now the right here and
now aguiri is one of 14 inmates selected
across four prisons to DJ and produce
shows on inside wire which launched in
March I am your host Joaquin mares and I
am back once again to help you get your
morning started off on the right track
though the station broadcast 24 7 each
episode is pre-taped and screened by
staff and often ends on a note of
encouragement you are worth something
and you are valuable and you can
maybe be on the radio one day right
there are people who might be watching
this who say how come this is a luxury
that you're able to do here I would say
to them what would you rather have us be
doing in here beating each other up
or creating music shows in radio and
helping our fellow men in here and women
in here do you find that it also
humanizes people who a lot of the world
forgets about oh absolutely
absolutely it shows that
that we are humans who
love and care have compassion regret
remorse and Aguirre says those emotions
can often be painful he was sentenced to
life in prison in 1992 for charges
including murder
driven to Despair and solitary
confinement 20 years ago akiri says he
tried to take his own life until
something came over the prison's radio
system the song Don't Give Up by Peter
Gabriel and Kate Bush
came on I don't remember what song was
on before that
I'll remember is that I heard those
words
don't give up we love you and uh
uh
I just forgot everything I was doing and
uh
here I am
you know I didn't die that day
it spoke to you
and that's what I hope to do is I want
this radio program
to save somebody's life to to lift
somebody up
that connection is what insidewire
general manager Ryan connero envisioned
you can come up to full all with the
faster after your voice or ends you know
we help launch the station in
partnership with the University of
Denver's prison Arts initiative the best
we can do when someone when any of us
commits harm is actually work to take
responsibility for that to repair that
and then go forward so you're trying to
create a community here yes there's a
community at each prison but whether or
not the people there both who work there
and live there view it or think of it as
that that's the question
[Music]
answer has
cure in real time after the minute Mr
Dean Williams Mr Dean Williams in South
programming on inside wire includes
inmates interviewing correctional
officers and other prison staff after me
please projection projection
articulation articulation inflection
Conroe guides inmates on the basics of
broadcasting editing and even using a
computer many for the first time ever it
seems like it's about much more than
just a radio station
it really is inside wire inside wire 95
of people in this country who are
incarcerated are going to be returning
to their communities and so when they do
that how can we be a part of that being
a productive positive journey and I
think inside wire can be a little part
of that how much do you take into
consideration victims concerns here
we take victims concerns very seriously
if someone is going to move from
committing harm to repairing that harm
that includes that person taking
accountability and if the victim wants
to engage in that dialogue then that's
how the person needs to show up inside
wire's name refers to wire as a
connection ready for some football you
know what I mean a connection that has
the power to travel 90 miles reaching
aguiri's daughter Amber vodka my boys
get a listen to him my husband and so it
makes a sense of like we're together
even though we can't be she was just 11
years old when her father was arrested
I'm gonna take you into some cool songs
right now now she listens first thing
every Tuesday Morning this show airs are
you proud of your dad I'm very proud of
my dad the strength that he has and the
strength that he's been able to withhold
this whole time I feel like most people
would crumble under
but he just strives and gets higher and
higher I think that's really important
to me
why is that because I love him and he
deserves it
he's worked really hard at being the
best person that he can be
though he'll likely never leave prison
aguiri is striving to be a better man
than the one who first walked in
I go to my cell
and uh
I feel like I've accomplished to
something something every day all you
have to do is be better it's as simple
as that
and the inside wire team hopes to expand
beyond the four prisons they're in right
now to others across Colorado and
perhaps in other states as well and you
really see the conversation it opens up
not only between the staff and the
inmates but also it changes the dynamic
between the prisoners as well but just
what he said all you have to do is be
better be better it's as simple as that
I also like what he said it shows that
we are something better than what we've
been told that we all that we are all of
our Lives yeah a very powerful story
powerful story and I appreciate the
broadcasting tips there as well of
course
projections
more tips to learn that was really good
you can see how it makes how good it
makes him feel and what he's doing for
other people too it also serves as an
incentive as well yeah yes because not
everyone gets to participate in this
program in that prison you have to earn
that that privilege to be able to do
this and it also changes I think their
identity in a way gives them purpose in
a Time that can feel very helpless Nancy
thank you we'll see you tomorrow again
on what to watch